how will we work in the future human
factory staff will be replaced by robots
they'll work efficiently and communicate
via an intricate network products will
be packed onto self-driving delivery
trucks computers will be able to detect
heavy traffic allowing drones to take
over transportation when needed home
robots will recognize their colleagues
from the delivery sector they'll accept
the goods discard the packaging and
carry on with their domestic duties back
in the factory robots will continue to
assemble 3d printed goods like
customized washing machines blueprints
will go out the window even entire
cities will be 3d printed well most of
the human workforce be out of a job as
some doom lady study suggests absolutely
not say researchers from the other camp
they think the advent of robots will
enable humans to complete the jobs
they're uniquely capable of those
blessed with good interpersonal skills
will thrive robots won't be able to
replace teachers doctors or carers
completely humans are capable of empathy
computers rely on pre-programmed
responses
this new era will create new
opportunities for people the demand for
financial advisors educational guides
and logistics professionals will grow
robots will create time for people
willing to work in the caring
professions at jobs that will be better
paid for from a horror scenario
contentment will rise as people pursue
spiritual wealth over material
possessions the future looks bright
thanks to our robot friends